en este vídeo nos vamos a enfocar más en
la idea de la evolución ya hemos
introducido esta idea en otros vídeos
pero aquí nos vamos a enfocar más en lo
que es y en lo que no es y como he
mencionado anteriormente es una idea
súper importante si intentaras entender
la vida en otro planeta
bueno tendrías que entender cómo
funciona la evolución y la evolución
como la conocemos se basa en dos
principios fundamentales se basa en un
principio de que en una población de
especies hay variación hay variación en
el fenotipo en los rasgos que tiene esa
población ahora la otra idea que está
relacionada con esa variación es que
tienes selección natural selección
natural si alguien trata de explicar
evolución sin variación y sin selección
natural probablemente no estará
explicando evolución probablemente
estará explicando otra cosa de modo que
esta idea si tengo una población de
círculos algunos círculos son azules
algunos son amarillos
círculos amarillos algunos son círculos
rosas y con seguridad existen rasgos hay
fenotipos que pueden no tener ninguna
relación con la capacidad de un
organismo para sobrevivir o reproducirse
en ese caso es probable que esa
variación continúe pero habrá algunas
variaciones
algunos fenotipos recuerden los
fenotipos son lo que se expresa frente a
los genotipos que son los genes reales
los alelos reales que tiene un organismo
pero la evolución ocurre porque
dependiendo de donde estemos en nuestro
entorno en el espacio y tiempo de
nuestro entorno
ciertos fenotipos probablemente sean un
poco más ventajosos que otros podrían
hacer que sea más probable que el
organismo sobreviva y se reproduzca es
menos probable que mueran o que no pueda
reproducirse y si dijéramos que estos
círculos son seres vivos y digamos que
en el entorno en que están ahora es
mucho más probable que se reproduzcan y
sobrevivan si son de colores más cálidos
si son anaranjados o rosas frente a los
azules por lo que en la siguiente
generación es más probable que los
amarillos y los rosas se reproduzcan así
que se van a reproducir un poco más
déjenme poner otros rosas aquí se van a
reproducir un poco más y los azules
podrían tener una menor probabilidad de
reproducirse con base en esta situación
que describí de modo que tendrás azules
pero serán menos azules y luego este
proceso se puede mantener por un tiempo
muy muy largo y en algún punto
probablemente sólo veas rosas y
amarillos y este es solo un fenotipo que
se puede seleccionar del que estamos
hablando puede haber otro si estamos
hablando de círculos podría ser de donde
es o cualquier otra cosa entonces la
clave es que necesitas esa variación y
dependiendo de en qué momento y espacio
te encuentres en ese entorno algunas de
esas variaciones algunos de esos
fenotipos los rasgos exhibidos podrían
hacerte más exitoso reproduciendo y
transmitiendo ese rasgo a tu
descendencia
y realmente quiero contrastar esto con
lo que algunas personas consideran
cuando piensan en la evolución algunas
personas consideran que la evolución es
un proceso en el que se pasa de lo
básico a lo avanzado y la razón por la
que a veces pensamos esto es porque
pensamos que muchos de los primeros
organismos en la tierra podrían haber
sido organismos unicelulares y ahora
tenemos estos animales complejos como
nosotros mismos que consideramos que
somos mucho más avanzados que estas
cosas tenemos trillones de células pero
recuerda los organismos unicelulares
continúan siendo muy exitosos incluso
ahora y algunos de ellos no son más
avanzados que las cosas que podrían
haber existido digamos hace 500 millones
de años o incluso hace mil millones de
años y aunque estas cosas pueden ser el
producto de la evolución lo que
significa es que a través del tiempo
tienes esa variación y luego con base en
qué variaciones que fenotipos se
adecuaron más a su entorno
esas son las que pudieron pasar sus
rasgos otro lugar de donde proviene este
concepto erróneo es que has visto estos
días que tienen estos simios donde los
primeros están encorvados
y luego se ponen de pie o más y más
erguidos y eventualmente ves una persona
caminando y oficialmente también somos
monos y tendemos a pensar que somos
bastante avanzados y hacemos cosas como
usar sombreros y otras cosas y entonces
decimos o si esto va de lo primitivo a
lo avanzado o de lo básico a lo avanzado
pero ese no es el caso recuerda que
incluso en el mundo de hoy no somos el
fin de la evolución incluso en nuestro
mundo hay muchos animales en el reino
animal que están en diferentes niveles
de complejidad o si queremos pensar en
la inteligencia sofisticación y sin duda
podría haber una realidad en la que
puedas imaginar que una colonia humana
se dirige a otro planeta y en realidad
es adecuado estar más encorvado en cuyo
caso las variaciones de los humanos que
son mejores para encorvarse podrían ser
más exitosos quizás necesiten ir a esos
túneles para encontrar algunos animales
para comer o lo que sea o para cultivar
y luego en este planeta esa variación
ser la que gane ahora otra idea
equivocada que las personas tienen en
relación con la evolución es cuando lo
escuchan piensan que eso podría deberse
al esfuerzo de un animal a lo largo de
su vida algunas de las primeras
explicaciones que la gente dio antes de
darwin de por qué una jirafa por ejemplo
tiene un cuello largo algunas personas
creen que algunas de las jirafas
primitivas podrían haber estado
esforzándose por obtener hojas en
árboles altos y por ese esfuerzo de
alguna manera estiraron sus cuellos y de
alguna manera podrían haber sido capaces
de transmitir eso a su descendencia este
no es el caso
la explicación consiste en nuestra
comprensión de la evolución en que
hubieras tenido una población de
ancestros de jirafas y habrían tenido
variaciones en sus longitudes de cuello
y debido al ambiente en el que se
encontraba esa población la variación
que tenía longitudes de cuello más
largas podría haber tenido una
probabilidad ligeramente mayor de
reproducirse y sobrevivir
y a través del tiempo los de cuello
largo se volvieron más predominantes en
la población y en algún punto podrías
decir porque los cuellos de las jirafas
no se vuelven indefinidamente altos
bueno eso es porque algunas variaciones
que tenían cuellos super largos incluso
más largos que las jirafas que tenemos
hoy podrían haber tenido otras
dificultades que hicieron difícil su
supervivencia y reproducción tal vez sus
corazones no eran lo suficientemente
fuertes y murieron de ataques al corazón
o tal vez le era más difícil escapar de
los depredadores a la variación que
tenía los cuellos demasiado largos
entonces es realmente importante
reconocer que la evolución es un
subproducto de la variación que ocurre
en las poblaciones y luego la selección
natural debido al medio ambiente en esas
variaciones y actúan sobre el fenotipo
actúan sobre los rasgos que se muestran
la evolución no es necesariamente un
proceso que va de lo básico a lo
avanzado y no se debe a que un organismo
individual de alguna manera se ejercite
para el entorno en el que se encuentra
hasta el próximo vídeo